you seem like one of the last people
that would show up in a Star Trek sci-fi
through it doesn't base it doesn't seem
like a TIG Notaro gig yeah I thought
that too I mean my I used to have my own
show on Amazon called one Mississippi
and I felt like it makes sense you go
Mississippi to outer space yeah but it
was it felt funny especially coming off
of that show and then once I was on Star
Trek I was like this feels so right I
can't even explain it I love it so much
you know I love this your your
character's name is jet RINO that's
right TIG Notaro as jet RINO I know
where did that name come from well they
had presented commander Denis Reno to me
and I was like I mean can't we like take
it up a notch and so as a little bit of
a shout out to Joan Jett there's two T's
on jet as well like hers so I said what
about commander jet Reno and and they're
like let's do it
it is it's someone had told me 25 years
ago I could have picked any name to be
on television it wouldn't have been
Conan O'Brien it would have been
check please you know if somebody told
me 25 years ago that TIG Notaro would be
on Star Trek do you get to kick ass in
this role I mean it's a sci-fi series is
it do you get to any fighting scenes you
get to shoot any lasers I haven't fought
anybody or shot any lasers but I have
had to you know run Wow on the resume
yeah well it's not even a run it's kind
of like a jog walk yeah thank you
slightly in a hurry you need to move
quickly yeah you know hence the name jet
but there's like
pyrotechnics and like explosions by my
head and and then you don't you wouldn't
see the mattress on the ground but those
kind of situations where you'd have to
jump onto a mattress so the explosions
aren't there when you're actually
shooting this no they are oh they did
it's there yeah yeah fully they're funny
it's funny funny this is commander jet
Reno
and I and I'm as much as I love the show
I I've said it a million times and I no
one can stop me from saying it again but
I'm terrible at the dialogue on the show
and I'm really bad and I must be a
problem I'm no Star Trek expert but it
seems like you better be able to say the
word yeah III do my best III try try try
to learn them and I really struggle and
I my first episode there I've I couldn't
get any of this well it's not that I
couldn't remember anything it's just
it's made up space
yes stuff right so I couldn't picture
what I was saying yes at all we're in
the parallax dimension we need to go for
herbs you know exactly you know this is
not good because I know you've told me
before your great dream your dream gig
is to play Tom Cruise's sister in a in a
role always rooting for that to happen
great as people can see you are built
for this part you are
if you want that gig you gotta sell
yourself as an actor you might I'm
jumping onto those mattresses you're
hired for you're hurrying for my Tom
Cruise face and yeah I just I would I
feel like by the time Tom hears about me
and wants to work together that he will
I will be able to to do my own stunts
and and meet him meet his level yeah
yeah because I know he jumps from
helicopters and climbs up buildings yeah
at this point I'm still just jumping
onto a mattress trying to get there I
have total faith in you I think I will I
think I think the next time you see me
I'll have adopted a couple of siblings
and I'll be starring in action movie
with you know it'll be TIG and Tom
Cruise yeah
[Applause]